[Music]
have y'all ever met before no but um we
got a chance to chop it up in the back
okay and he told me he's going to let me
reenact the scene that that's right was
showing I'm going to show him some
stunts I know I'm like man can I tell
you something I've only ever been to one
basketball game yeah and I saw this man
oh really that's the one the one
basketball game was Nick's heat and uh
and you guys won yeah well
I how we do that's how we do it had
nothing to do with me being there I
think you I'm going to take some credit
he has no Talent over there um no were
you into sports growing up though yeah I
soccer like so your football football
football yeah I just did a translation I
know you were being nice all my friends
are going to be like what are you
talking about I know I know America we
just took the name and ran with it with
a different sport you're welcome compl
different game I like it but I it's a
that's a hard one though that's a lot of
cardio soccer did you ever play I did
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I played every
single day what I did every lunch break
in the morning in the evening yeah I was
obsessed oh my God don't you but I
wasn't an athlete well you know that's
that's why my dream didn't come true you
know wait wait you know you have to work
so hard and uh you do but playing every
day if I'm playing every day I'm calling
myself an a athlete that's that's what
I'm calling myself wait so okay so wait
was there anything you ever grew up
doing that you loved but you weren't
good at yes okay we want to hear that
cuz you're so excellent at basketball
what did you suck at Dwayne singing oh
singing yeah every now I want to do a
Koke with you me too every day terrible
edit every day in the shower everywhere
well your daughter can sing so she got
it for me okay
[Music]
[Applause]
M thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home